denise it was one of president biden's
first actions when he got into office
ordering government agencies to
immediately take action to require mass
on all public transportation
sally jaramillo telling us what is being
done locally
to ensure bus riders are safe we've all
been wearing masks everywhere we go
however there are some still choosing
not to especially when it comes to
commercial and public transportation
but starting at one minute to midnight
wear it or you may not be able to get on
a bus
or a plane the centers for deceased
control recently issued guidance that
strongly encourages the wearing of mask
on surface transportation modes
late friday an order was published
outlining the mass requirements for
people inside transportation hubs
as well as on public transportation such
as airplanes trains buses taxis
etc this order applies to both
passengers and employees
angela castro is the rtc chief strategy
policy and marketing officer she says
they take very seriously
their responsibility to help ensure the
health and safety of passengers
contractors and staff among some of the
enforcement procedures if a customer
refuses and does not state they have a
medical condition or they can wear a
mask
officers may refuse them to ride or
enter the facility
now if a rider removes their mask once
entering a vehicle
the operator will focus on the safety of
operating the vehicle
and will call dispatch to send an
officer for support with the mask
is very important right now because it
lessens on the virus because i did have
the virus last year so i know what it
feels like and i don't want no one to go
through that so
i've been there so i think the mask is
very important
rtc has invested more than 14 million to
support and promote the safety of
drivers and passengers during the kova
19 pandemic
they have distributed more than 9 000
mass to the public to date
as for officers on routes rovers and
facilities they have mass to offer to
customers reporting in las vegas sally
jaramillo 8 news now
sally thank you the mass requirement
remains in effect
until the 11th of may